la 38e édition du festival international
du film sur l'art devait se dérouler
cette semaine à montréal
les représentations en salle ont été
annulés mais le festival aura lieu en
ligne qui est aussi bien et
documentaires j'ai reçu plus classiques
ceux des grands artistes comme léonard
de vinci par exemple mais aussi sur les
artistes locaux comme mouffe qu'on va
pouvoir découvrir dans un film et ya
aussi toute une sélection de films d'art
lui le film hyper créatif qui vient du
monde complet pour 30 dollars les
festivaliers pourront découvrir
l'ensemble de la programmation sur vimeo
[Musique]
de son côté une festival de courts
métrages regard de saguenay propose dix
oeuvres présentées en primeur sur le
site de la fabrique culturelle à la
fiche this coup de coeur d'ici et
d'ailleurs à découvrir gratuitement
[Musique]
même si les musées sont fermés au public
plus d'une centaine d'expositions en
lignes sont disponibles gratuitement sur
le site musée virtuel point ca histoire
art science nature il y à des
expositions pour tous les goûts et pour
tous les âges
[Musique]
envie de voyager sans prendre de risques
google art et culture en collaboration
avec plus de 1200 musée et organismes
patrimoniaux à travers la planète
propose des visites virtuelles moma
musée d'orsay
guggenheim les plus grandes collections
sont accessibles en un clic en musique
le maître de new york propose
gratuitement chaque jour la captation
d'un opéra
le coup d'envoi a été donné lundi soir
avec la présentation de carmen de
georges bizet sous la direction de
yannick nézet séguin
sur ce bonne semaine et bonne visite
virtuelle qui signe avec 100 vaches arty
radio canada montréal
[Musique]